if the criminal justice system were
apparent we would call it abusive and
neglectful it punishes too much
my name is mark Kleiman I'm professor of
public policy in the UCA School of
Public Affairs I teach courses in
methods policy analysis and drug abuse
and crime edit the journal drug policy
analysis I wrote when brute force fails
because I'm both excited and angry angry
about having much too much crime and an
intolerable number of people behind bars
and excited because out in the field
people are doing things that could
change that there are more people buying
bars United States than in any other
country in the world we have more
prisoners than China does not per capita
we have more prisoners than China does
with 5% of the world's population we
have 25 percent of the world's prisoners
basically we've got a criminal justice
system that doesn't know what every
competent parent knows that you change
people's behavior by giving them clear
rules and by enforcing those rules
consistently and quickly and fairly the
worst thing about our criminal justice
justice system is its randomized
draconian ism we're very severe in the
way we punish people but we do so very
irregularly very erratically the basic
reform is the substitute swiftness and
certainty for severity the average
probation violation leads to no
punishment at all but an occasional
probation violation will lead to six
months in prison that's the best
possible way to fill up your prisons and
not change anybody's behavior typical
probation department does drug testing
and tells people that they're not
supposed to use and if a test comes like
positive the probation officer says
don't do that again and the next time it
happens their probation officer says
don't do that again
and the third time the failure patient
officer says you know if you keep doing
this you're going to get in trouble and
the fourth time he says this is your
last warning and about the eighth or
ninth or twelve time there's he and the
judge and the probationer might be off
to prison for six months lunacy he had
no way of knowing that the last last
warning was really the last warning
if you've got a large number of
violations and can't punish all of them
there are two approaches you can punish
more or less at random in which case
everybody learns that mostly is going to
get away
with it where you can pick some subset
of offenders of offenses of locations of
times pick some part of the universe and
say okay here's the rule within that
part of the universe so concentrated
enforcement means deciding what you're
not going to tolerate and who you're not
going to tell are we doing it directly
communicating that threat to the people
whose behavior want to change and then
carrying it out
if the fenders were perfectly rational
crime control would be easy ratchet up
the severity of the punishment to the
point where even a small probability
being caught means it's not worth it
that's all we've been trying for the
last thirty years and it basically
hasn't worked everybody is more
sensitive to immediate consequences than
to future consequences everybody is more
sensitive to certain than too uncertain
consequences offenders are probably more
like that than the rest of us they're
more reckless they're more impulsive
therefore it's even more important to
move the consequences close in time to
the offense and to have the link be
highly probable there's a trade-off
between severity on the one hand and
swiftness and certainty on the other I
mean we don't prolong time that
swiftness and certainty are more
important than severity what's not
adequately understood is that severity
is the enemy of swiftness uncertainty
severe punishment can't be Swift because
there's a lot of due process involved
and it can't be certain because you're
chewing up a lot of resources right so
that 25-year mandatory sentence under
the California three-strikes laws that's
25 people who can't be locked up for a
year and it's a little strange that the
people who are allowed us to about
opposing wasteful government spending
haven't noticed that long prison terms
are wasteful government spending
I agree that benches an important part
justice the tone-deafness
of official criminology and the legal
Academy to the need for vengeance seems
to me has contributed to the to the
problem I mean if you acknowledge thee
for vengeance then you can say but it
ought to be proportional the resistance
to using DNA testing to find out whether
somebody's guilty comes from the
prosecutors the cops and the victims not
all of them but often enough and the
psychological mechanism is clear enough
right from the victim's point of view
what matters is that somebody was
punished for that crime to validate the
victim but a matter a little bit but
there was the right person course higher
incarceration to some extent this work
because people who are in prison aren't
committing crimes on the outside now if
we counted the crime rate inside prison
the crime drop would not have been as
dramatic I was a strong advocate of
building more prisoners back when we had
fewer than half a million prison cells
the first additional half-million was
well worth doing the next million and a
half not so much we may do with the
fifth as many prisoners we have now
everybody else in the world does that
we're gonna figure how to do that as Pat
Nolan says right now we're imprisoning a
lot of people were mad at the only
audience people were afraid of there are
three groups of people or be in prison
and only three there are people who do
such appalling stuff we're gonna make an
example of them so Bernie Madoff people
who are violent criminals and whose rate
of crime is high enough so it's just
worth the 40th bucks a year to not have
them in our hair and they're people who
won't behave on the outside
put him an ankle bracelet on takes the
ankle bracelet off okay he's picked
himself for prison cell everybody else
we can adequately punished and control
in the community the key thing about the
American system is that we have police
chiefs who are appointed by elected
mayors and prosecutors district
attorneys who are themselves elected
officials they are very sensitive to
what the voters want and what the voters
have wanted ever since the crime move in
the 1960s he is revenge on the criminals
in some ways I think the voters were
right to say a crime
big problem we should do something about
it unfortunately they were badly misled
by their politicians maybe thinking that
that random severity was equipment was a
good solution we should be striving for
having as little crime as possible with
his little actual punishments possibly
we should do as much as we can to make
threats do the work of actual
punishments
this is Shelley's principle the perfect
threat is the one that never has to be
carried out
you